welcome to this afternoon session and
our first picture is nothing nina and he
will tell us about something local
coming at works and what to do with all
these big graduates
okay so i normally start my lectures by
saying that please feel free to ask and
make comments
are we on
okay good
okay so i normally start by my lectures
by asking the audience to
not be shy and ask questions but i think
with this audience
we're doing fine so
again but but the the principle remains
don't wait in the end and
and besides i'm pretty sure that i won't
be able to cover everything that i
wanted to speak about so it's okay we
will go as far as
as we can so
my main purpose is to highlight
a two sets of problems
one is fairly easy
to explain the other one is
is easy to state but more difficult to
understand what is standing behind them
and and do two things one
put these problems in context and show
that they really
are connected to lots of things that i
think many people here care about
and we
illustrate that
they're quite
mysterious and challenging and i think
should and will occupy a good deal of
research in in the future
so uh
just that
you know
in case you you like
you know to wander around in your mind
and not so much to concentrate let me
ask a question
and then you can go back to this and so
on but i i will i will get back to this
so so here's
here's a specific
i want to start just with with the small
definition
g is a graph and all my graphs well no
not all of them but
the the graphs in which the game is
taking place they're always going to be
large you know i would be specific about
this as we
see so g is a large graph and k is an
integer and i want to speak about the k
profile
of g
what is this well there is a list a
h1 to hm
all a
different isomorphism types of k vertex
squares
and you ask how often
do we find each one of those in here so
this is a vector
so the k profile of g is a vector p1
through pn
which tells you pi says
if you at randomly at random pick
k vertices in g what is the chance that
the graph that you hold in your hand
is
so
a very fundamental problem which is
what i would call a basic question in
local graph theory
is what does
k profile
a large graph
look
so this is going to be a very basic
question around which much of what we
will do today will revolve so that's
question one question two
is a little bit more vague at this stage
and we will get back to the i think this
is this should be perfectly clear what
the question is question two
so this is a local to global
asks a what
so i'm
explicitly saying this is at the moment
not
very
well defined or
but we will get to that we will make
this question concrete what so what
global
properties
of g
does
its profile
encoder
what conclusion what global conclusion
can you draw from given the when you're
given the the k-pop idol sorry
m
yes
no no no k is we're looking at k vertex
subgraphs and there are m different
graphs okay and different
some offs and types of of k vertex
squared and these are all different yeah
that's a complete list that's a complete
list okay
so this question is
you know i think we are among friends
here somebody said
we know that theoretical computer
scientists like to tell the rest of the
world that they do something practical
well not always this is a hundred
percent but they they here i must say
this is this is honest so i think this
this is a question that at least for me
is motivated
if nothing else by my interest in
bioinformatics so let me speak for a
minute or two about about this because i
think this is one of the things that
makes this kind of question really
interesting
and this is a really so that's the
second part of
my title how to how to read a large
graphs so
let us go back
a little bit and imagine for a moment
that the whole field of statistics
you know still doesn't exist or just
starting and somebody comes and shows
you
a million numbers
that came from something from observing
people from observing animals from
whatever
and asks you what can you tell me about
the thing that i have observed
well so okay so we know
i think you don't need
a lot of
mathematical background to say okay let
me draw this distribution and then i
have a
you know a list of perhaps i would start
to work out which distributions are
interesting for me and i i work out and
i perhaps in this case say
after i i prepared the little
mathematical background let's just say
well this look looks pretty much like
normal perhaps i'll evaluate the
parameters perhaps this i can work back
and look at the the objects that were
observed and so on and so forth so this
is really you know
a very
good description of
of what the the probabilistic or the
statistical point of view is telling us
but
what happens now in in
i think many areas of
science and engineering and so on is
that you what
what the observation gives back to you
is not a long list of numbers but often
big graphs
so just to be concrete and give you one
example out of many many so i i want to
say this is an important question and i
certainly do not
claim that i know a solution to it i
only want to suggest a direction in
which we can go but the question is is
honestly and really important
instead of this you get big graphs so as
an example concrete example that that
i i was
you know somewhat involved with but but
there are really tons so i'm just
mentioning this because i know this
first hand so protein protein
interactions of of
that that come from biology so you have
some organism you don't need to know any
biology to to understand what i'm saying
now then you all know that proteins do
essentially all the biological functions
human well depends how you count but
let's say 25 000 or 100 000 it depends
exactly that doesn't matter so much
proteins are there in in
this particular organism another
organism and and proteins come in
contact
and you describe this whole thing by
means of a graph
so now you have let's say a graph with a
hundred thousand so what replaces this
is that you get
a graph with a hundred thousand vertices
and really what do you do with it so i'm
i'm honestly saying this i i think this
is a major
uh challenge for for today's science in
more than than one field
and
i i think that we
to a large extent we don't know what to
do
so people are doing all sorts of things
with it but this is a major problem and
and one thing that
also it's it's it is being practiced
it's not a new suggestion at all
is so what to do with big graphs
and you know it's
i'm trying to be perfectly honest here
i'm not suggesting that that's a full
answer and so on but not nothing of the
sort but at least an answer a decent
answer
is that you can look at exactly you have
a big graph you look at the k profile
and now you have something similar to
what we've been doing in in statistics
perhaps you have a list
not too long of generative models of of
graphs
which are the analog of a list of the
important distributions that we study in
statistics and in probability and then
perhaps you can
try to do something similar to this then
you can say aha this is such a big graph
from this profile
i can guess that this is a graph that
was generated by this that process i'll
work back you know what the critical
parameters are and perhaps i can
so
you understand the the idea of dense
grass or sparse grass
because
in fact okay
but i
the the short answer is is dense
uh but let me just say that of course
that there are
the the all these questions are
interesting and relevant for spouse and
one thing that you can easily so let's
say in this situation one thing that's
just a little exercise with inclusion
exclusion is that if you understand the
same profile just for connected sub
graphs essentially you know everything
relevant so in those cases
you would probably want to
okay
do to look at just the connected graph
so these are the
and of course you know if
if we have good answers here
which we haven't perfectly formulated
yet then this is certainly very useful
so this is one reason to to
believe that this this general question
is indeed
significant
so
just to connect back to things that
we've already
seen today of course
this is uh at least conceptually
closely related to property testing
which i don't think i
need to to to define for for for this
audience but
uh
let me just say let's say take you know
one of the the classical things
bipartiteness
so if you think about it the fact that
we know that being bipartite is is
something that
that can be tested
this means
that
the k profiles
of
bipartite graphs
so this distribution
or such distributions are well almost
disjoint
from those
that are
epsilon file
from being bipartite
and
in fact i think there is even in in this
area there are interesting questions to
ask uh so to what extent i mean how how
large
does does the sample have to be in order
for you to be able to to tell the the
difference between the two so so that's
it again another a computational model
in which a local things are relevant and
then
again as a background for
why
i
i believe so so one of the things that
that made me believe that this is really
a good approach to to to the this
important question of studying big
graphs comes from from this theory of
graph limits
i i don't know how how well the the
audience
knows this but let's let me quickly go
over this this is a theory uh that
with quite a few participants i think
the two
main leaders of these
are the
nazi novas and balochsegati but there
are lots of other excellent people who
were involved just if you're interested
there is a wonderful book
recent book
that lovers wrote about
the subject so if you're interested and
i highly recommend it you can look at it
certain
beautifully as he always does
so
the the the idea is this so
let's
let me try and illustrate it from from
this perspective so
how can you i mean is it really feasible
to to to learn something interesting uh
from from looking at the these
constant size profiles
uh so you would like so
let me state a theorem here this is
a major theorem in this in this whole
theory a
you have a series of graphs
and you would like
you you seek a notion
that this the this the limit
as n tends to infinity
exists and let me even call it w which
is the the common thing this is
what's called the graph on in in this
theory
under which conditions are we able to to
say that such a thing exists so there
are at least
one
very well
studied and tested method that
mathematicians have been using to to to
define limits which is whenever you have
a distance
anywhere if you fill in a metric space
then you can speak about
question sequence
this is small
if m and n are large
so once we have a metric on graph
we we can speak about question sequences
and therefore
some notions of of convergence to to a
limit and then you use
something which is called the the
box
metric which essentially says
at least four graphs with the same
number of vertices what is distance
between two graphs you try to to match
the vertices in the best possible way so
that they agree on as many uh
pairs as possible and then there are
some variations of this
and so the main theorem a major theorem
i mean they say it says that gn
tends to limit
a limit in in this sense
in the magical sense if and only if it
has the following property
for every
graph h essentially if if the profiles
tend to a limit
so for every graph h the density
of h
in gn
tends to a limit
so
in other words this concept of
really coming from some infinite object
or being generated by
some in this particular case fairly
simple method the these graphs
is equivalent exactly to to agreement in
in the local
this
profile
a single sequence of graphs
yes yes yes yes that's a necessary and
sufficient condition the the this thing
exactly captures the
so that's another reason why
uh
i i really believe that this is okay
the box metric so it's easiest to
explain
if the two graphs
have the same number of vertices so how
what is the distance you just take a
one-to-one
mapping between
the vertices
so as to minimize the number of pairs on
which they disagree so the fraction the
least fraction of pairs in which you
have to fix it this is their distance if
they're if they're yes you're with me
okay and if if the numbers do not uh
match then think of of a graph as being
you know we think of it as a matrix the
adjacency matrix think of it instead as
as a function where of zeros and ones
and then
what replaces this this one to one
matching is any uh
measure preserving map that you can do
here on the same thing okay so that's
been
okay
so
i hope by now you're convinced that this
is
a worthwhile undertaking to to
understand this but are we you know are
we completely
in the desert with no not at all uh
there is a lot of
highly relevant and beautiful
mathematics that that is that we can use
here and this whole thing is is closely
related of course to perhaps the
best developed part of combinatorics
which is external graph theory
so when you're doing extremely graphic
let me just quickly i think remind you
stuff that you all know so the
grandfather of extreme graph theory is
two on steroids
which you try to capture the intuition
that if a graph
has high density has lots of edges then
you expect to find in it
let's say big clicks and so on and
we tell you things it tells you things
like
a graph
of density
bigger than
r minus 2 over r minus 1 contains
a
kr so in particular a
plug here r equals 3
so you see that if a graph has density
more than one half and
the boundary is tight
so plug here i equals three you see that
if a graph is density bigger than a half
it must contain that angle and this is
tight because you can take
this complete bipartite graph and in
general
you can partition your vertices into
three parts for r equals four and so on
and so forth so this is a first case so
this is really the the beginning of a
really wonderful and deep theory this is
from the 40s so it has been developed
a great great deal
since then and one of the main questions
that people study in this area
is this
function ex
pen and h
so this is the largest so you can either
either think about it in terms of
counting edges or density it's the same
thing the largest number of edges
in an n vertex graph
it contains
no copy
so let me just say that
as opposed to some stuff that we would
do later on this doesn't have to be
induced okay the click doesn't matter
but i'm not talking about about induced
and so
so i'm you know
talmud says that if you give proper
credit you save the world okay so i'm
not talking we're taking this this
job on me today so i'm going to be quite
bad in giving in giving credit so my
apologies to alive and dead people and
those in between
so
quantum
sorry
of life yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly okay
good
so
the same theory with with a little bit
more of work tells you that this
is
anxious 2 so i chose to work with
numbers
where 3
is the chromatic number
of the graph h so if this number is at
least three we plus little of one
so if if
h is the graph of chromatic number three
and above then we really have a very
satisfactory answer here and and of
course one of the major problems in
external graph theory is to understand
what happens for bipartite there we know
much less but just as for example
something that will
show up
later so this is c4 is this graph
which is bipartite that we know
is state of n
to the three halves both upper and lower
bounds so that is understood but there
are very few bipartite graphs which
this is known so why
why is external graph theory so closely
related to to what we do because of
course
if you know the profile
the profile encodes
uh in particular easily it encodes the
density of the graph right you can
easily work out
what how many edges if i tell you the k
profile you know how many edges the
graph has so this question about
understanding the the profile
is much more general than than one of
these basic questions uh
in external graph theory
okay so
let me now mention so i want to okay one
one
major thing that i want to speak about i
hope i will have enough time to to do
justice to this so at least let me
at least for sure mention
the name so
a major tool that has
come into the the
arena a few years ago is rasboro's
big algebra
but
i hope to be able to at least
briefly explain to you because
this my feelings computer science don't
don't i'm not sufficiently familiar with
so perhaps it's a good idea to speak a
bit well
at least i see one expert in the
audience but
still i think they're also
non-experts
so perhaps i'll say a word about this
and and the way i want to
get to this is from the question that uh
that rasborov
wanted to attack and solved
which is also in the in the still in the
field of external graph theory so in
fact i said that
this is the grandfather of extreme graph
theory
honestly there is
actually even one one generation earlier
this is from the forties but there is
the case
acquisite
was done by mantell i think in 1907 in
quite a forgotten dutch
mathematical journal so the case article
is three so if a graph has density more
than a half then it contains the titles
and and and this is tight but you could
ask okay but let's say
that it has density
0.6 or 0.73
can we show that it must contain a lot
of triangles so the question was so i
want to take this and and ask two very
natural variations of this so
question one that i want to ask here
is a
given the density
how small
can
you know what let me already
give this name this is the
density of triangles
right now it's uh
well perhaps not some stranger that i
call it p3 but this will this name will
have more meaning or sense in a few
minutes so that's the chance that i take
a triple and i find
triple vertices and i find a complete
graph
how small can this be
so when the density is is below a half
the answer is zero
and from these pictures you can guess
i think it's it's not hard to guess what
what the answer is
and the answer is that essentially
what you do is you
move from from this when you're above
the half you do something like this
where these two are equal and and and
bigger than this
that's so this is a unique
construction and that's the one that
that
that minimizes the the density of of
triangles and this in fact a proved
using his method which as i said
i hope to at least give you
an idea of i'm starting to suspect that
perhaps not
so this is one question that is now
completely solved another question on
which roswell made a great progress but
is still
not solved uh when was asked already by
by turon so two runs
problem
for
three uniform hypographs
so now we are not dealing with graphs
but with collections of triples and and
you ask the same the most natural first
question in fact you come back to to
mantel and and you ask something like
a
which
number
of triples
forces
so in the same way that the triangle is
the first non-trivial dense thing so it
forces
this thing four
points and all the triples on them
and again there is a natural here things
start to to get more complicated because
uh
the thing that is conjectured to be the
optimal is not unique and as any one of
you who ever solved an external problem
knows
many many extrema make such questions
usually difficult
and this this has been open for 70 years
certainly one of the
most
considered highly considered or highly
regarded questions in in combinatorics
and roswell was able to make very nice
progress on this so he holds the world's
record at the moment and various other
things but the question is is still is
still open
so
so all these things uh really i hope
give you a
some idea
on the
the fact that when we want to to deal
with this question we are completely
uh
it's it's enough that we're on our own
there is a
there is theory to to draw so let me
mention two
more uh
concepts that are related to to this
idea of a local profile
which are very important
but again i won't be able to
do them justice
this is always going to feel confusing
this is quasi
quasi randomly so
speak about sudo
quasi random girls
so
of course the the most again i'm
assuming that you all know
the most basic uh
construction of random graph is is is
gnp
where every pair of vertices
uh adjacent with independently with
probability p
and
quasi random quasi-random p
is saying that this is
similar to gnp
and here i just want to so again you're
looking at the the profile and one of
the
there is a beautiful uh
again um
at least i should mention a name so so
under thomason started this and there is
this famous and beautiful theorem of
chan gram
and wilson
so what does this mean a there is
their basic theorem
says that there is a whole is a list of
seven or eight properties of graphs
which capture the the fact that graph
locally
looks like like this so the density
it's very close
to p there is a whole but the the the
most amazing part
is that this is equivalent to the fact
that the number
of and now let me be
of induced
c-folds
is
correct
so
i'm being very shallow here
but it would take me a little bit more
time to to say this so i just want to
give you the you know the the highlight
of this
uh
so if you want to understand the
the local b so this in particular if
this is correct as as it should be in
gnp let me so
then it follows that every
or the whole
a profile
is
as
in gnp
so it's not a difficult theorem at all
but it's a very surprising
fact if you if you see this for the
first time so this is one one
type of a
property or behavior of local profiles
that
we we may consider another thing which
is more subtle but as you'll see
very fascinating and again very
mysterious and and i think again quite
relevant
possibly to to to practical situation is
a k universality so that's a definition
now i'm not telling you the theorem but
the definition
you say that g
is k universal
if it has
a
full
k profile
so everything every every k vertex graph
appears there with with a
with positive probability
a
as i expected a
i am in trouble with the time
so
okay let me
so i think i i i hope i gave you enough
of an overview on on this thing now let
me
try and get a little bit
into
some details or get
more concrete about uh specific
questions let's just speak about the
three profile
a the three profile so
what is there well what kind of of three
vertex graphs are there is this then the
probability of this i call p0
p1
p
so
here is a very concrete question you
know what such four tuples are possible
now let me just make sure i i don't i'm
not interested in in all sorts of
strange phenomena that happen in small
graphs i only want to
understand what happens for large graphs
so i'm looking at this
subset of alpha
which consists of all
x0
x3 such that there exists
a sequence of graphs that go to infinity
with
p
super 3 of of g tending to this vector x
what is this
it's a four-dimensional set in fact it's
three dimensional because of course
these numbers add up to one
and we'd like to understand this so this
theorem of of the the this theorem of
gives you information here's one more
piece of information that this is stuff
that
that we know from the 60s
which is a
cute nice exercise which i will not do
for you because i'm starting to be short
on time but that's an easy
and a nice thing so for example even uh
answering the question what are the
possible
values of of p0p3 so in recent work with
the
well at least my co-authors i have to
mention by name wang
navis
peleg
in sudakov
we are able to to derive
information about this and for example
we are able to to
tell what are the possibilities for p0
and p3
uh
in particular this set is not if you
wondered the set is not convex it has
also it's it's a strange set
we know various things about it
uh
and we understand also with the same
people uh what is possible when it's
triangle free
we have a full description of that using
this method of flag algebra as well able
to to to solve this case
but just to illustrate how how bad the
situation is let me tell you
one very fascinating
fact which i find really
important and and
completely
not understood
is there is there a set of limit
for objects sequences that you can study
instead of studying
i don't know i don't know if you have
such an idea i would really
be glad to it's a good idea but i i
don't know no
here's the more restricted question of
whether you can use a particular graph
limit that achieves each point
what is achievable just what is
achievable i i don't even
so so a if
four tuple here
is in the set if you can find allow
let me say for every epsilon and every
end you can find a graph bigger with
more than n vertices whose free profile
is absolutely close to this point
i understand that
maybe james was asking is okay there's a
more restricted set of points which you
can actually achieve as a particular
graph limit
where the whole sequence of g no it's
the same thing that's the same thing
that's just that's the same thing right
but your limit what are objects your
graphs might contain more things than
you can achieve with ground right he
speaks about things using things which
are not necessarily graphs okay
but okay so
i i think these are okay there are
things here which it seems to me this
theory of graph limits
is unable to capture and i hope there is
woodsworth good likes to make fun of me
because i once told him that i wanted
when i was a child i wanted to i was
hoping to discover some a lost continent
so this is the closest that i that i get
to this so let me let me tell you what
what it is so let's let's look at this
let's look at this inequality
this inequality is tight why because in
g and one half obviously both p0 and p3
are in eight
so
this made elders ask the question or
conjecture
well i give it these
strange names so now we move on to
let me put it this way with three
vertices
you know it's
conceivable that we're able to to to
answer this but with fall we're really
in bad trouble we really don't
understand the situation so let me
illustrate with this
he asked whether this is
bigger than 1 in 32 so this is for four
vertices the empty graph and the
complete graph why again for each one of
them one of the 64. you get one in 32.
and this is not true
thomason refuted it
now he's his graph
and then redland students these graphs
are very strange
they make i mean we don't understand we
don't know we have no good guess on
where the minimum of this is
and and this is for me an indication for
example that
when we're dealing with with ramses
theorem
the lower bounds the best lower bounds
that we know today come from from gen
one half or gnp for when the uh
and this indicates to me i'm what i
think what this is trying to to tell us
is that this is not the right place to
look this is an indication of of a lost
continent that i mean we
really have such a small variety of
graphs that we know and work with and
this is and there are lots of other
things which i already say i won't be
able to to get to today uh these are
indications that there exist graphs of
types that we really don't know so i
think this is much more than an
incidental thing i think this is an
indication of the existence of very
interesting graphs that we completely do
not know so what i want since i see i'm
really short on time is at least spend a
few minutes on local to global because
here there is
one of the most beautiful and profound
open questions in in combinatorics which
at least i want you to be aware of
in fact i'm erasing exactly what's
relevant here this this notion of of
universality
so this is the erdesinal conjecture
amazing conjecture
and it says the following for every h
there exists an epsilon positive
such that
if g
is an n vertex graph
with
no
induced copy
of h
then a
list one of the two either alpha of g
or omega of g
is at least n to the epsilon okay this
is the the click number and independence
number of the figure now let's let's
understand what this
says and
i hope i can convey to you my excitement
with this question
in general in an vertex graph a random
vertex graph has a click and an
anti-click of login
that's it that's the largest and it's
really beautiful if never saw this but
really one of the fundamental
discoveries of the probabilistic method
great
uh
what this says that if your
local profile for some fixed k is
incomplete if you are not k universal
this has a huge impact on the overall
structure
so the click and anti-click one of them
at least must jump from from logarithmic
to a power
let me tell you so so just a pool
a poor man's uh i don't know
version of this something recent that
that
i did with the students so this is
really
the result here is really simple it's
the
technical not not particularly difficult
but i think it suggests
something that may be very interesting
and so this is a recent result with
a student of mine alvaro morgenstern
says the following
if
p0 and p3
less than
this number
then
g
is
the universal
the important thing about the result is
tight
so the important thing is that this
number is is less is is above 8 and 8.
so if i wrote here
1.24 then i could only all i could say
that this graph is made of gold because
such graphs simply do not exist
so i that would be true you know in an
empty way but there is a bigger number
so what this suggests to me is that this
is
a
you know a tip of an iceberg the types
that's another
uh the perhaps there exists theorems of
this general type
so that you don't have to
forbid a particular graph but it's
enough if you limit
uh
how how often you see them if you put
upper bounds on those then
no i can no so
no
you know me i love if you know
if if i could i would have done it ages
ago i wouldn't wait for you again
so i can tell you in particular in this
case we know that this doesn't imply
five universality about four we don't
know
but as i say this result per se
is i mean the proof
is a proof you know
numbers some optimization you prove it
so i think in itself
this is not uh
particularly you know
super duper but it's
presumably but i don't have yeah at the
moment i don't even have a good
conjecture my meta conjecture is that
there could be theorems of this general
flavor but i i don't have anything
concrete to to work with so i think
seems like my time is up there is still
a lot of things that i could have told
you so if you catch me in the corner
i'll
be happy to share them with you but it's
time to stop so i stopped
uh more questions
that you get all on all three
possibilities all these four
possibilities are the p1 and p2 are
positive as well
is there any general information of
those like their semi-algebraic sets and
some general principles
under no i don't think anything like
this is known
oh that would be interesting to tell i'm
not even sure that this is even even
very basic things like this are unknown
but perhaps you see
so you know i've already mentioned there
can't be a talk in combinatorics without
some mentions of of elders so
let me tell you one more of his favorite
stories he used to say you know where
a 3-3 the ramsey number is six that
probably you saw in high school then r44
in and we don't know r55 and rcc so used
to say that if the merchants
land on planet earth and say you know
either you tell us what r5 is or we blow
this planet then you should get all the
mathematicians all the computer
scientists and other computers and and
try to
but if they say the same thing with r66
then the only plausible thing is to try
to fight them back
and i i feel something a bit similar
about
the three profiles of graphs
i i believe that this is something that
you know with enough effort this is i
mean there are still many things that we
don't know
but this is within reason i it seems to
me
at least if nothing else because of this
counterexample of thomason that i said
that the passage from three to four
there is is we're really there we really
are in in in open waters we really the
situation there is very poorly
understood doesn't mean that we have to
you know we can ask questions like this
we can get bonds which if not tied at
least we can do something
but the whole thing is is still very
mysterious let me add one more thing
with one comment which i didn't even get
to mention
i spoke only about graphs but you can
also speak about the local theory of
permutations which is very interesting
there are some nice things there are
tournaments almost every combinatorial
object that you think about you can
speak about local
phenomena and local to global phenomena
it's really a very rich
subject
what do we know exactly about this
conjecture is there something that was
proved maybe yeah yeah yeah yeah so
ernest and heinen themselves
proved this which is already it's not
difficult and very very pretty very
clever but it's a clever but not a very
difficult proof
so that already is a
the first open case
is this
it's not known if h is c5
uh
right yeah yeah but what happens is i
mean
excellent people have done really
very impressive work on this but so far
all the ages for if you know what that
is in for all the edges for which this
is known
are perfect
so the first imperfect graph is c5
and this is the first case that we don't
know
nothing
please did you say 1.1591
it's a construction it's a specific
construction and we are able to show
that this construction is the you know
you can find it on my homepage so i mean
i i certainly don't want to say anything
bad you know it's a student's work but
and it's a decent work we're going to
publish it i'm happy with it everything
is good but i think the main point in
this paper is not so much this
particular result but just the
possibility that this really reveals
hopefully a new type of you know a very
general phenomenon
no no it's it's it's a number it's
something there is some fourth degree
first degree equation and then you take
the root and you do this with that and
stuff like this no no it's it's um
could you say something about thomason's
construction
okay so i can say something
no no no no
but you know should be and that will
keep you going for another 20 minutes as
you should feel free to leave if they're
not interested
so
okay so i i can tell you one thing about
this i had at least two graduate
students who i i tortured with this
problem and both of them
asked me to to switch subjects
so
no no and they both did and they both
did very well so this is just okay i'll
say more about this because the in
hindsight there were there was also
something that
a mistake that i made okay
what i'm unhappy about so i it's really
funny because i'm very friendly with
andrew thomason and and we meet often in
above alpha and so on and over well i i
wine he bill uh discuss this at length
and at some point he said i didn't even
know that this was such a great result
you know you convinced me it's a great
result so i think it's a great result
but both his and and the the uh rebel
result uh are bad
in the sense that they construct a
finite graph and they blow it up
the funnel can rattle is is something
that i can i could even i wouldn't do
this now but if you want i can show this
to you in private you start from a graph
with two to the ten vertices there is a
very simple rule on how this graph looks
like and then you blow it up so so far
this is what so this is this project
that i had two students uh give up on a
to find an honestly asymptotic counter
example to to be
i i don't view this as in honestly i
mean it's perfectly okay and extremely
interesting but i still think that we
are looking for an honestly asymptotic
counter example to this this irish
conjecture and that that we still don't
know i can also tell that in hindsight
some of the things that we tried and i
should have seen this but i didn't was
that some of the things that we tried
it was really a stupid mistake on my
side because they were quasi random and
quasi random cannot refute this so you
have to be one one thing if you're
thinking about this problem beware of
quasi-random examples they're not going
to solve your problem so that's one
simple warning that i could add
it's not huge there are many i don't
know 100 or things like this he has
no
not
no no no no there is nothing that no no
they are very clever and and he wrote
about these three papers each time he
gets this thing to be more conceptual
and so on but really if you want the
simplest to describe example then it's
the final cradle
so let me say two more words you take
all the binary vectors
here is what it is you take all the by
you partition the number from zero to
ten into two parts
and part a and part b you take all the
two to the ten vertices and you connect
two two
guys in in a with an edge if the hamming
distance is in part a that's it so all
you have to the whole thing boils down
to partitioning the set zero to ten into
two parts
can you is it possible to explain in
like two worlds why s is not convex
like yes
yes here is uh this is something i
intended to do but you see
you can have of course p0 is one and p3
is everything else is zero and you can
have p
three
is one
uh
just the complete graph and the empty
graph
but so that's one of the things that we
did with the pseudo-covenant student and
with a student eval palette
a
something like this there are two
that's that's the possible range of the
pair p0 p3 so that's the p
zero axis p
three axis you see that it's not convex
in particular this started from a
question that i had initially thought
was going to be just a little exercise
i want to show that a
so when you see this and when you think
convex you ask yourself is it possible
that both of them are half
if you think about it for two minutes
you realize this is impossible and i
wanted to find out the best theorem of
this song that says at least one of them
is at most something
and and indeed this is one of the things
that and which i thought was going to be
an exercise but no it was fairly hard
i i don't have i will not tell you now
but
in some sense again this is not
discovering any new continent but it's
it's
it's difficult that i can say this is
difficult and and i think any
combinatorialist would tell you
i end
even some computers like this
if you think about it i think if you
have any any any exposure to to external
graph theory you would think very easily
that that the best construction for such
a thing is
well if you use it that we we used to
say a a
red island in a blue sea so you take a
subset of the vertices you connect
everything by red you see everything
here is red and and all the rest of the
edges are blue and now you have to
optimize on on which fraction of the
vertices are you right
so so
the theorem is that always
the smaller of this is
0.26 something which is again a number
that comes from optimizing all this but
but no it's far from being uh even even
the raspberry area no it's not convex
it's far from it's far from convex
that's the optimal there this this is so
when you do this what's blue and what's
red you get these two curves that's the
upper and then then we prove a theorem
that says that everything in between can
be realized and
where are the edges
no no they're blue so everything here is
red or everything here is edges and
everything here are known edges all the
opposites
anymore
okay we continue at three thank you
foreign